[Music]
something different
welcome guys does that music get you
pumped up I don't know
sound like somebody drowning and playing
a guitar at the same time to me but
that's just me being judgmental and that
is music sent in from a man named tiny
sand who and this gentlemen hit me an
email
he hit me where it hurts you know what
I'm saying the email and he hit me in
the email tiny sand whoo I get an email
yesterday and first I see the name in
the name space it says tiny sand who I'm
thinking tiny sand who you know well
what is it turns out it's a man tiny
sand who sent in music and that was it
right there and that's voodoo child that
he played himself and that's voodoo
child and that's a cover of Jimi Hendrix
and he sent an email it's a cover of
Voodoo Child by Jimi Hendrix yet another
Magic Man from the South home of the
Blues Thank You tiny Thank You tiny I
appreciate that and I know they had a
boy named small Alan growing up in my
neighborhood and who could do who could
hang off of his daddy's scrotum and and
Weiner and some people know that and not
in a sexual way
that's not a sexual thing you know
sometimes people were you know his daddy
was in the in the Eastern European
vaudeville in the circus you know and
whatever that was I'm sure a real rotgut
establishment you know and uh and he's
and but small could hang off of his
daddy's when his daddy would drink his
daddy would drop drawer and small could
grip all no his daddy's wiener in and uh
in balls you know both of them not at
the bottom like a [ __ ] you know like
a [ __ ] you
[ __ ] on a punching bag I'm talking up
at the top you know where the where the
rubber meets the road he could grip him
at the top and just hang there hang off
of his daddy's you know fertile
accomplishment pieces and that was
pretty wild that small could do that in
the small Allen fella that grew up in my
neighborhood but anyhow tiny sand who
I'm sure that's probably the small Allen
of of India maybe of West India I'm not
sure but thank you for that music man we
appreciate it
I've gotten a lot of music sent in and
one of these days I'm gonna I'm gonna
but she's gonna play you some of the you
know what next week I'm right now next
week I'm gonna play you that but some of
the ones that have been sent in man and
some of them are great some of them are
really not even great or just not fit
for this show but I'm gonna send you the
type of stuff that people have sent in
that they felt was a complimentary to
the show and to me it's someone was just
it's striking and it's interesting and
it's it's great man it's something else
dude some of us sheer [ __ ] as well some
of it is sheer [ __ ] like somebody just
you know I mean it's something else man
but anyhow welcome to this past weekend
October 23rd okay and I know Halloween's
right around the corner and also I want
to welcome you to this past weekend
because we have our new first charter
sponsor and that is gray block pizza
18:11 Pico Boulevard Santa Monica
California on your way to the beach if
you like pie in your face go get that
hitter at gray block they got it GRE y
BL Ock they got the Frenchy the quad the
Bella goat meet yourself up you know
what I'm saying get that beef in your
teeth or go for the famous salad pizza
if you lean and out for the beach or for
prom or for a second marriage if you
trying to cut some gut hit that salad
pizza P trying to cut some gut if you're
Italian or if you're not it's the place
gray block pizza order online it's in
Los Angeles on Pico Boulevard gray block
pizza GRE Y great pizza calm we're happy
to have them on board as our first
charter sponsor I'm very excited and
excited for you guys to be here with me
on this past weekend what's going on
what did I do you know what you know
what I did this weekend man I did what I
wanted to I did what I wanted to you
know what it really was a lot of it was
nothing
a lot of it was nothing dude I got
trapped watching that so montt that show
mind hunter have you seen this you seen
mine hunter you know it's on Netflix and
uh and it's about serial killers you
know people that want it that kill
somebody and then also want to kill
somebody again because apparently if you
kill someone it's enjoyable
who knew that honestly sometimes I think
it's sometime in the dark recesses in my
mind I probably knew that you know that
if I just wrap my you know meek little
poems I mean I got that I got the I got
the I got the the fingers of a of a of a
talented cat you know I got real meek I
got the fingers of like somebody who
makes pasta or you know makes pasta in a
cave you know I got real just I mean if
you set my if you painted my fingers
brown and just hung them out the window
a bird would land on them you know I got
the Moline little branch just little
branch giblets you know almost could
easily be made out of wood and not a
nice wood either you know maybe teak
something not very sturdy but those are
the kind of hands that I have you know I
mean I'm just probably I'm a half hour
away from carpal tunnel I bet you know
I'd do a Rubik's Cube and I hit I get
hit with that but that carpal tunnel you
know I'm saying I got meek fingers dude
if I started to fall off a cliff and I
grabbed for a rock dude I would I would
definitely still fall off a cliff I
don't have that kind of you know that
hand strength you know I could maybe
throw a pool ball like a billiard ball
could throw a billiard ball about 45
feet I got these meek fingers but I'm
heavy in the girthy and the shoulders
I'm girthy in that upper and that I got
that upper roar I got that uproar you
know like I took a deep breath and it
just got stuck inside of me forever
that's what happened I'm thick up top
you know I'm thick up in that chesty
I'll probably have 50 or 60 ribs a bit
if they crack me open you'd have a bunch
of damn
I bet you'd have a bunch of brothers and
sisters showing up at the park because
it's time to barbecue if they crack me
open and you know that but yeah I got I
got caught in well first I want to thank
tiny again for the music and look tiny
I'll tell you this tiny I don't know
about music you know I bet never been a
big music man you know you're talking to
a guy who's seen goo goo dolls four
times you know you're talking to a guy
who would probably go to a Miley Cyrus
concert you know if I had a box seat am
I staying down in the bottom with the
you know with the children and pedia and
P do that are down there because that's
P do country and Miley Cyrus is a place
where I bet a lot of people that are you
know P do and Eva either even out there
just have a good time and not even to
meet children because it's kind of that
kind of fun music where everybody enjoys
it but you know you're talking to a guy
who you know I've been have also been to
see that widespread panic
you know I've caught maybe six or seven
of their shows you know I've slept out
in a van in a parking lot with a bunch
of people that's you know men and women
smell the same and have the same haircut
and you know they got different you know
they're eating grilled cheese is out of
each other's you know crotch it's just
just wild stuff you know people that are
you know selling homemade biscuits out
of a van and laying next to dogs or
wolves at night you know and eating
spider webs and you know who knows what
else
gingersnaps i've been around those types
of people that you know go to string
cheese incidents and do the other stuff
and listen to fish you know and ride
around and learn a juggle and [ __ ] even
though they're in their early 40s I've
been around some of those damn [ __ ]
you know architects whatever they are
[ __ ] architects but you know so I don't
have much of a music but Thai nice and
who sent the music in and I'm grateful
for it but yeah watch that mind hunter
if you haven't seen this now first of
all the thing is about mine hunter it's
about people learning that serial
killers think differently and I've
always been obsessed with you know with
serial killing a little bit I've always
liked those shows for some reason my
mother had us watching America's Most
Wanted as a child that was the show that
our family got together and watched
and man that was I discern being so
scared and I don't know if my mother
probably should not have let us watch it
but my mother we were adults early
because we there weren't a lot of you
know she kind of let us make our own
choices really in a lot of ways and you
know of course as a kid you're like oh I
can handle whatever but I remember
hiding behind the sofa sometimes at some
of the stories and and I but I got into
that stuff doing some of these shows
it's addictive you know you won't see a
friend for three or four days you know
like man are you okay would you have the
flu and then like nah man I uh you know
I didn't have the flu dude I had Ozark
you know I had a I had a heavy case of
the Ozark I came down with it and then
my lady came down with it you know and
then spouses start fighting because
you're on different episode you seen
these episode fights well he [ __ ]
Frank you know he thought he'd be cute
come in drunk and watch two episodes
Ozark without me [ __ ] you Teresa you
know you always doing you watch six date
lines without me so what are you even
talking about
but you got couples getting into episode
fights you know and it's ruining bedroom
stuff you know because they don't want
to be in that you know people on
different episodes and they feel like
that that's how they relate anymore play
some Scrabble which your wife would play
some damn cards take a night off sit in
front of each other look into each
other's eyes but with that said man I
love some damn serial killing and I've
never had a strong taste or
knowledgebase for music cuz you know
what happened to me out for years I
drove around I wouldn't even listen to
music in my car maybe I could be a SK
saral color because that's the kind of
serial killer things things serial
killers do you know I and I think I just
got addicted to listen to my own
thoughts I was so trapped in my own head
I would just drive around and listen to
my own [ __ ] thoughts that were on
repeat dude it was like five tracks all
of them were [ __ ] so you know at least
whatever you sent me tiny sand who is
better than me listening to my own
thoughts for a little bit
but we got a lot going on we got a lot
going on this week people are getting
fired up because Halloween is coming up
hello and I got the hands for Halloween
dude oh I couldn't the the only person I
could probably strangle about a I bet I
bet I could strangle about a 13 month
old anything over than that I would need
assistance that's how I got week fingers
man I got week fingers dude I got
fingers that are just you know like I
have trouble sometime with a ziploc you
know for me red and you know yellow and
blue most of the time still just make
yellow and blue I got to call somebody
in because I'm just I don't have that I
don't have heavy pressure and my fingers
and I think I get that from my mother
you know she has but she's strong but
she got them lean fingers I think or
maybe my father I don't know maybe my
father I mean my father buds huh I got a
look at his fingers my father was you
know 80 years old when I was 10 so I
think anything I get that's not working
good I think it's maybe it's safe to
assume that I got it from my father
you know the genetics on there probably
you know I might have these senior
citizen fingers but but yeah that mine
hunter I got trapped and you can get
trapped in these episodes man you're
watching you wake up in the middle of
the night you go to piss next thing you
know you're four episodes deep in you
know Breaking Bad cuz you never started
it you know it's just it's it's intense
out there and stranger things it's
coming back in a week and a half just a
lot going on but I I I got I got caught
watching that show that mine hunter and
it's about serial killers man and I've
always had a fascination I remember when
I was young I used to collect those
remember they used to have these blue
and white cards they were white but with
blue it was missing person and I think
the number was 1-800 the missing and
they would send him to you in the mail
every week or every other week and it
had pictures to pictures of children and
one was a one that when they went
missing and one was what they assumed
they looked like now and I collected
those
and I remember I would look at him all
the time and some people are thinking
what's a serial killer typing thing to
do but I did it because I remember I
just I I don't know I felt sometimes
like I don't know I don't know maybe I
wonder maybe if I would had been a
missing person or something I think I
felt so out of place in my own life
sometimes that that maybe I thought one
of those cards would come a new bike oh
this is you know this is where I've been
or what's been going on you know I think
I just felt missing you know I don't
know why man I just but I sympathize
with those kids I really sympathize with
this kid for some reason I would collect
him and I would look at him all the time
and I remember one time I thought I saw
one of the children so that's a little
bit of a dark thing that they think
about this morning but also at the same
time it's not you know I was looking for
these children you know I was keeping
tabs on some of the different kids that
were coming across that we're missing
her allegedly missing you know but I
always had a fascination with that in
America does right now America has a
fascination with that there's a new
podcast as well out that's called dirty
Jon that uh that you might want to
listen to I just listened in the first
episode today it's pretty good but I
think that that's something you might
enjoy but that's what I did this weekend
man I went to some music
this guy Moses some knee I mean if
you've heard of this gentleman or not
but he's good man I hadn't listened to
I've been to a music show in a while but
Moses some knee s um any why it's a tall
gentleman originally from Ghana grew up
in California and man I've never seen
music like this this dude has he's
playing the guitar Psalm and he's
playing the piano and he's got these
pedals that are looping everything and
his lights going on in this he's doing
this kind of interpretive dance but it
was it was next level man like I'm into
a warp zone it was like somebody you
know took a big bat and knocked my head
right off of my body and my head was
just flying through space and I wasn't
in any pain and my eyes were open and my
ears were open and I was just traveling
through the galaxy that's what this man
created with this music so if you get a
chance to check him out
Moses
is this guy's name mos es s um n ey I
met the gentleman in person but it was
pretty cool but yeah I've been to some
[ __ ] music man I remember you know when
I was a child we would eat drugs and go
in there you know first concert I ever
went to was Marilyn Manson you know
speaking of spooky stuff and me and my
buddies Scotty who was really fancy I
mean a real Fauntleroy of a boy you know
kind of nice-looking you know look like
his whole body like it just was made out
of conditioner cuz I didn't know they
had conditioner you know I'm saying
solid probably you know maybe 19 or 21
or something you know but I
but he looked like he just you know like
like just damn baby goats came at night
and just licked his body while he was
sleeping you know and did his hair with
their tongues because he looks soft like
that he looked not soft in a bad way but
he just looked you know fully manicured
by God like just natural you know he
looked like them baby goats was taking
care of him at night you know he looked
clean he looked real clean you know he
looked like he could he could go a
couple days without brushing his teeth
if he wanted to it looked like he could
brush his teeth with his hands and it
would have still come out really clean
he just looked that clean you know and I
remember me and him went to Marilyn
Manson and we met this do big Richard
then I've told some of the story before
I ended up getting busted he got busted
actually for pee filing out there you
know it allegedly but he went to jail
for it and he was a senior citizen and
and he took us dropped us off at Marilyn
Manson bro before they were huge when
they were just popping off just popping
off they were playing at this probably
250 person venue called the Rendon Inn
in New Orleans and me and Scott are
they're underage 14 years old listening
to Marilyn Manson all right and I
remember being in the bathroom urinating
and some man walked in and he's like
what are these [ __ ] kids doing in
here right and these people are all
dressed up this was a Marilyn Manson was
like when they were you know he would
cut his drummer open onstage with a
bottle and the drummer would go to the
hospital
like really go to the hospital you know
like not like we're just gonna get some
pictures of him at a ready matter at a
24-hour you know you know saloon or
something medical saloon this one they
would really go to the hospital and and
I remember being in the bathroom urinate
and some guy was like what are these
[ __ ] kids doing in here and me and my
buddy was in there urinating separately
you know because I'm gonna do joint
urination and I never have even when I
was a child you know shoulder to
shoulder dude give me at least a half
inch bro we don't even [ __ ] know each
other you know what I'm saying
unless we're in the military dude we're
not touching each other's bodies and
holding on to our wieners at the same
time dude you know what I'm saying now
if you want to go off at a game of gay
chicken we can play that all day but as
you know his young adults standing here
shoulder-to-shoulder come on now so I'm
in there my buddy's in there we're like
the guys like what are these [ __ ]
kids doing in here and some other dude
goes I don't know but I'm sure somebody
will [ __ ] him up and we were a kid dude
and you hear that kind of [ __ ] you're
just like Jesus man the world is not a
safe zone you know and I think it was
right around Halloween time when that
happened to man and so I remember that
got us in the mood to be spooked out for
sure dude for sure fun Halloween man
coming up the kids just talking to my
buddy on the phone he said he got his
son they got a Batman outfit but the
muscles already built in and I'm asking
whoa what is that [ __ ] when I was young
dude if you got that Batman that thing
was a piece of [ __ ] dude remember it was
just like it had the Cape it had that
mask dude
they had this girl and um they had this
girl in our neighborhood big Melissa
even though she was young they called
her big Melissa and I mean I could you
could guess why they called her big
Melissa but I mean she had the biggest
head I've ever seen dude wider than it
was tall I mean that head was probably I
would guess it was it was probably eight
and a half by eleven but like a sheet of
paper maybe
but sideways you know long ways and I
remember she would put that that the
mask on for the Halloween costume didn't
but when I was young it had the side of
the mask and we cut in your face dude
and that band on her head was so tight
dude she's good it would push her whole
head up into the mask almost like a
cookie right it would just be cut out of
her on the sides man just I mean just
chirped out around the sides that thing
would just cut into her skin so after
she took it off her whole face for a
couple days they'd been molded into
whatever she was you know like a little
gummy bear or uh what else did they have
gummy bears or Winnie the Pooh or you
know a cat it was just mold her face
like a cookie that thing would stick to
her face and she had to have help
getting it off that mask but those
things were dangerous in the Batman
costume when I was young with a piece of
[ __ ] you know our buddies telling me
that his son has the muscles built-in do
when I was young you had to damn hit the
gym if you knew I don't if he was nine
years old dude you better hit the gym
dude you know I'm saying you better get
on some high quality breast milk do you
better skip a baby in the tit line and
catch a little bit of breast milk and
put on some weight if you want to fill
out a Batman costume you to make your
own you know you had to grow yet get
ready for it you know if you wanted to
be something you had to be it you know
if you wanted to be a you know a Army
War veteran you know you might find you
know you might break your arm a couple
weeks before and be in a cast you know
or you know hobble yourself you know and
tie your legs together you know for a
couple days before so you're practicing
that hobble so you look really hobbled
you know we went in a Halloween with
purpose
now these kids getting costumes with the
muscles built in hit the [ __ ] gym
young buck or young lady once you hit
the gym for six weeks before October
31st and fill out that costume naturally
quit cutting corners you know that's a
problem sometime with America you know
these kids want to cut corners but I
just remember it being different man you
know I remember it being different I'm
when one kid wanted to be Oscar the
Grouch
right but he didn't have like a can or
anything he just duct-taped this hue a
bag of trash to his back dude he looked
like a I mean he look like a homeless
and into turtle really he just I mean
he's just a huge bag of just garbage and
the garbage is liek just a garbage he
found on the street you know about a
street and he just duct-taped it like 40
different ways around his back and the
bag was so heavy it kept weighing him
down so sometimes he fall back on his
back and we have to you know push him up
by the shoulders and get him back up
right but he was supposed to be a damn
Oscar the Grouch but no can you know I
guess kind of like a naked Oscar the
Grouch you know a little bit mildly
naked because I didn't have that can on
him but yeah I remember Halloween man in
our mirror being fun but I've been
getting into these TV shows and I'm just
saying that someone more addictive you
know they're addictive man you get into
these shows and they're dissident off'
they're dissidents it's almost I don't
want to say it's it's too addictive but
it's almost I feel like dangerous
sometimes when this binge watching comes
out because it's just it makes it harder
if you're not in control like I'm not in
control sometimes you know and I have an
addictive personality
and I will quickly get into it and then
I can't get out you know so that's tough
TV watching for people that aren't able
to get in and out of things very easily
and that happens to me man that's
exactly what happens to me what else is
going on this weekend I did some comedy
sets had a good time I saw Brendan
Schaub saw Rogen I saw Bobby Lee guys
that I love we got the new I'm doing
this pilot for Comedy Central if you
live in the California area and are a
man who's been going through something
or you are a woman who has a husband or
boyfriend he's been going through
something wild
you know that's kind of manhood type
stuff you know maybe he's afraid to pop
the marriage question or maybe you're
afraid to pop the whatever it is I need
men who were dealing with men's stuff
you know men who are dealing with men's
stuff hit me up on the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three were putting together this pilot
and it's going to be pretty neat just
want to hear some stories
see if all we can possibly incorporate
one of them into the pilot project and
that project actually is based on this
podcast so pretty cool man if we didn't
start this and get this going
then that opportunity doesn't prevent it
present itself so that's pretty awesome
and we're doing some really really neat
stuff it seems like what else is
happening man I I I remember other
costumes that I had as a kid you know I
remember being a firefighter and I
didn't really have a costume dude and my
brother had this little wagon right so
we filled that wagon with a little bit
of kerosene and he he would pull the
wagon and had a and we lit the kerosene
he pulled the wagon that's the fire
right and then I had like a bat and like
a fake gun and I was running behind the
wagon of fire shooting it like a fighter
you know so it's kind of a I mean I
guess even at that time was kind of a
play on words and it was a little bit
I'm his little damn ridiculous in
hindsight you know but but I remember
being a firefighter when I was a kid I
remember being Where's Waldo I remember
being a I remember being I was on a boat
one time people were using each other's
pubic hair to make you know mustaches
and beards because we don't have any
spare hair as a child I was Raggedy Ann
a couple times on accident and I was
Raggedy Andy what else what else was I
as a kid I don't remember maybe when I
was a baby I might have been a damn
pumpkin everybody dressed as a baby up
like a pumpkin I saw I saw my little
nephew got a costume and he's gonna be a
Native American you know and he's gonna
do it honorably I think you know so I'm
sure I hope he honors them as he gets
out and does some trick-or-treating but
that's it man Halloween's coming up I
saw some people out in costume this
weekend and guess what
[ __ ] those people because that's too
early to be out in costume you out 1213
days before Halloween you're out there
running around come on man come on man a
bit much in it for a
volts for adults and also ladies be
careful if you invest something your
child if you got a child out there and
you're just gonna buy your child a $13
costume but you're gonna go spend three
fo hundred on yourself you know looking
like a you know if you gonna dress up
like a [ __ ] snail or something you
know maybe even it out maybe you know
get you something else likes you know a
conservative maybe be a conservative you
know a conservative calamari and and get
your son maybe our daughter maybe a
hundred dollar outfit but get something
good you know but happy Halloween
everybody I mean I think well one more
episode before Halloween saw Mabel get
into a little bit more then but uh but I
just wanted to wish everybody a happy
Halloween what else is going on not much
the news I'm really wants much of it you
know Trump's that you know always you
know tweeting at everybody and their
fight and I just the whole thing is so
much ego I know that Hillary's gonna run
again Hillary's gonna [ __ ] run again
and she's gonna and I bet she would lose
I bet you would lose man
this whole thing is this twisted ego
universe man
you know it's so crazy how egos and
bruised egos all these politicians man I
would vote a waffle iron into the White
House if I could
cuz I hope this whole thing that's why I
think Trump's hilarious a lot of times
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] you know
and that's bad and some point it's a bad
example you know cuz you want somebody
to give you know but he's just like this
crazy kind of business guy who has
complete empath you know it's like but
then sometimes that's what a lot of
America is I think sometimes we don't
want to we don't want to be realistic
about Trump because it's like I think he
embodies some of exactly what we are you
know exactly what a lot of America has a
[ __ ] as a you know as a cloth sometimes
it feels like has become just this you
know it's about making money it's about
business you know it's about cutting
corners you know I don't know man
but it's just funny because Obama made
fun of Trump years ago with that speech
at that dinner and then
Krum wants to show him back he's like oh
ah you know what I could I could have
your job and he does and he gets his job
and then Hillary loses and she's so
butthurt and then she's gonna and I know
I can just tell she wants to run again
ran did it's just like the WWE it really
is it's just like professional rasslin
bra and that's why for me it's exciting
because it makes people are fired up
people are angry good or people are high
good whatever you know I've never I've
never depended on politics to mccann
effect on my life like they were gonna
bring I don't need that you know for my
comfort
now it would get super scary after you
know there's a war something crazy like
that breaks out you know but at the same
time you know is that what we I mean
we're at a point where it's like
somewhat something's gonna happen Mother
Nature is about to whoop everybody's ass
she's already doing it you know I don't
think we're I don't think as humans
sometimes we're being we're behaving we
are if it's behaving but as are we are
we best serve serving ourselves you know
as humans I don't know you know I don't
know but I ask myself that question and
I look around and base that on my own
eyes you know I mean the me that you
know the news is going to a level that
shits right the news will get people
killed dude you believe you followed the
knew the news getting people killed dude
no everything's a problem dude yahoo has
changed so much I used to go to Yahoo to
get stuff
do go read the lines on Yahoo they're
headlines it's so bizarre you're like
what is this smut you got to keep your
face out of the smut David that's what
you got to keep up anyhow that's enough
of my politics I just think it's just
everything has become the WWE the rock
I've heard real rumors in Hollywood this
is real real stuff that the rock is
gonna run next time the rock you know
and the crazy thing is that Hollywood
Korea they helped create Trump there's
no that's that's the funniest thing to
me sometimes you had all these people in
Hollywood like are so angry about
Trump but Hollywood helped create him
you know that platform somebody in
Hollywood made millions and maybe
millions and millions and millions of
dollars off The Apprentice you know I'm
sure net something I don't know I don't
know what Network it is or what produced
whoever's attached but no accountability
there there's no way that he wins if he
if he doesn't have that format that pot
form that show that that show you know I
just there's just so many and I just
think it's funny because I love seeing
politicians just yell at each other and
fight there it's just like professional
wrestling but when it comes to the
reality of things what do I do I get up
in the morning I get out of bed you know
I try to be of service to my friends and
family I try to be of service to others
I don't do it all the time I don't do it
every day
perfectly but I try I keep making an
effort I take care of my side of the
street mother Teresa said you want to
change the world go home
love your family I'm not out of here
fiercely [ __ ] and all day about this
you know these people are ruining this
because people are ruining that politics
never these people these politicians
never did anything for me and that's why
I think you have it's like a lot of
people are shocked out that oh Hollywood
are that you know it's now the biggest
thing is that like oh it's opioid in
America
that's who voted Trump in office dude
most of America is just poor people you
realize that you realize that
and guess what poor people like dude we
like professional [ __ ] wrestling bro
that's it we want to be entertained oh I
get to be poor while the rich keep
getting richer and the disparity of
wealth in America gets greater and
greater and while politicians seem the
second they get elect you can tell this
the whole thing these you can see in
their eyes that most of them are already
thinking about their their the wealth
they're gonna make on these speaking
tours afterwards
well the least that can happen is it can
be an entertaining [ __ ] in four years
and you might think t oh that's crazy
that's not how poor people think I grew
up these people I know how they think
I get it I'm not trying to like shove it
down E but I'm telling you that that's
how poor people think man that's how a
lot of people think people are just
tired of [ __ ] watching the same show
it's the same show alright enough about
me man I'm sorry to go off on those deep
end sometimes but you know I just what
I'm just I'm just such a mortal you know
I'm so mortal God and I'm just trying to
stay alive I think you know but I just
I'm fascinated that that I'm just
fascinated of what what everything's
kind of turning into and I think change
is good man I think change is always
good it's the hardest thing sometimes to
go through and to recognize while it's
happened but but change is always it has
to occur and I think the end the outcome
is always greater than what was the
energies or whatever that was happening
before you know except for dying dying
probably not a cool change you know like
a won't be seeing you guys for a while
you know that's how that's probably not
a good one but enough about me man we
had some great calls this weekend first
I want to tell you guys though that
November 14th through snow November 16th
through 19th I will be in Huntsville
Alabama at stand-up live Huntsville and
also I want to tell you that Dollar
Shave Club is the smarter choice get a
great shave at a great price
conveniently delivered right to your
door and when I use my Dollar Shave Club
executive razor with their dr. Carver's
shave butter have you heard of dr.
Carver oh he makes some not a face
butter the blade just gently G just
gently glides give him
such a smooth shave you two can make the
smarter choice by joining Dollar Shave
Club for a limited time new members get
their first month of the executive razor
free with a tube of their dr. carver
shea butter for only $5 and free
shipping after that razors are just a
few bucks a month you can get this offer
exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com slash
weekend
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash weekend
for a limited time you get your first
month with the executive razor for only
5 dollars with free shipping check that
out
support the podcast you can also go to
patreon.com/scishow on th e o vo n there
will be exclusive footage extended
footage from today's episode there and I
want to thank all my patreon oars that
gun squad you know for support and and
all of my patreon those bumpers
everybody from being a part of things
all right guys let's get into some of
your calls you had some some this
weekend and I appreciate it man what was
going on in your lives here we go see oh
hey there's Tommy Judson your buddy from
Ohio my wife and I saw you and Baltimore
and met you last year maybe this year
dirty Tommy man or clean Tommy I'm not
starting to get a good look at you but
Tommy Judson good to see you
good to hear your voice man I'm glad
your wife had sound like y'all still
together let's hear a little bit more
and I did get offered a threesome I got
offered into a mixed bag over there
threesome in and that was in in in
Baltimore
onward anyway I was EMTs for a lot of
years and you reminded me of the time
when I went into a some dude literally
in Ohio
somebody's literally fell off his
barstool and died we went in there to
try to realize him yeah the cardiac
arrest and we were doing CPR and you
know jabbing him with needles and child
and as I was as I was giving him CPR
looking literally looking into his dead
eyes really wild yeah dead eyes a while
dude
that oz I mean it's crazy we go from you
know being that human to being having a
little bit of fish and it's really quick
you know having a little bit of fish and
it's really really quick let's hear more
the people in the bar were still sitting
there eating their french fries sniffing
their their chicken wings in the blue
cheese so yes people are weird around
this this death is on raw or like yeah
people are weird around death and I know
you're referencing Tommy as well I I
caught I spoke last week about how
wasn't around that choking incident you
know I saw a woman was choking to death
and her husband just kind of massaging
her shoulders and kind of rubbing her
neck a little bit like she had a [ __ ]
you know like she had a knot you know
like she'd had a tough you know a tough
job you know a tough afternoon doing you
know tries and traps or whatever but you
know this this man was just you know his
wife was choking and other people
sitting around and just or almost don't
know what to do
don't it's a it's this this pause that
comes over everyone so yeah I mean
that's pretty fascinating that people
are still eating snacks is very Rome and
I feel like that's one of the things you
see back in Rome you know when they got
a you know they got a vulture you know
seven or eight vultures fighting a you
know a pickpocket you know they put him
out there in the ring and they're you
know you know and they're chasing him
and you know you know biting his
kneecaps off and all that [ __ ] and you
know ripping moles off his back all
these vultures or you know just you know
pecking moles off his back and stuff and
and and the whole time the crowd is just
sitting there cheering and eating snacks
and everything that's very Roman and
it's amazing I said on we get so Roman
when somebody's dying you know I
remember being at a buffet as a child my
mother had a boyfriend he said mom would
take us to the Holiday Inn buffet up
there on Saturday and they had a waffle
a waffle Longman they had a man up there
in a fancy hat that made waffles dude
and he looked kind of I guess Italian
but he made he make these waffles you
know he'd go get that waffle of mine and
we did not get along my set that but we
would be nice with my with my mom's
boyfriend but we would be nice to have
some time to get that waffle you know
get that hitter in our mouth
you know get that bait that [ __ ] big
hot you know that big hot [ __ ] French
cookie man or whatever it is I don't
know if waffles are friends they sound
kind of friends to me you know AFF le
are they lovin that food I'm not sure it
could be French but anyhow but yeah I
feel you man when people when somebody
die and some people still want to eat
and I think some of that's guttural too
because you see somebody else is dying
so you think okay I better sustain and
the first thing you do boy I mean he'll
if somebody's breastfeeding next to me
I'll [ __ ] I'll take a hit off that
after that [ __ ] that nipple bag you
know what I'm saying because he the
first thing you want to do is sustain
you know and sustaining is the
number-one thing I mean it's like at the
end of Grapes of Wrath that lady they
got a lady with breasts and she's
breastfeeding her own family you know
people take our or strangers or
something taking hit off a woman's
breasts for survival so I think if you
see somebody dying you know [ __ ] you
might just crack open a bag of a Frito
Lays or some snow peas or something and
and put them in your mouth to keep
sustaining but I appreciate you calling
and I think sure your service out there
as an EMT dude you know you guys are out
there on the front lines of [ __ ]
overdoses and all of that [ __ ] and
that's got to be pretty heady dude so
thank you for calling if you have a good
story actually if you're buzzed me in
sometime and let it let me know on the
hotline with some of the stories you
have on I'd love to hear them and that
hotline numbers nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three as well so if
you want to get involved in and you're
not involved in it hit the hotline let
us know what's going on okay let's keep
cruising here we go this is your boy
from Ohio CC thank you for calling here
we go
Buckeye Nation here's the situation I
have a manager at work she is married to
another woman
female lesbian oh yeah if that that's
female lesbianism Allman and I have a
same haircut as a lot of those women and
I see a lot of them checking my [ __ ] out
to online I see all on instagrams trying
to hock my [ __ ] gender neutral style boy
word up let's hear more brother
hitting on me and they're both like
solid eight Ohio eights Hey Dude in Ohio
a it's an Indiana nine baby that's what
they say let's hear more and hitting on
me and my wife actually won denotes that
would make things weird that works if I
dabbled a little bit in those dark arts
and also do you think that if my part
took in any of this it would make me
feel you know emasculated in any way to
have you know maybe my wife enjoying
this a little bit also wanted to know
maybe Wow
okay that's a lot right there so you
have this option that's called a bass
trap - they call it a bass trap dude
when they got two and two lesbians are
hitting on you you know they're trying
to get you in that bass trap and yeah
look man I mean that's I feel like
that's intimidating if both of them are
eighths I have a feeling one of them's
an eighth and one of them's a six I'm
just gonna be honest that's what I have
a feeling you know because sometimes
it's hard to get you know to real
hitters at an eight that are lesbians in
the Midwest I'm guessing I'm guessing
one's an eight in one's a six I'm just
guessing bro and that's okay
you know that's me being a little bit
judgmental there but that's that's
that's safe you know but hurt because
I'm saying is you know one of my buddies
one night came up to me at a bar and
he's like man I got these five girls
want to hook up with me and I looked at
him and he's like they were all twos you
know and he's like dude five twos make a
ten right we've all heard a reference
like that before but I'm like dude
that's yeah you know at a certain point
you're not even what type of sex is it
if there's five you know and these women
were all the same height all little
women five little women one penis it
sounds like a um it sounds like a
Japanese game show more that he was
getting involved in you know but it can
be intimidating you know if you get in
that environment with the two ladies and
that now I'm a bass trap is when two
lesbians get you into you know they get
you into the bed but then one of them
that killer you know what I'm saying
because one of them is always at Sugar
Ray Leonard
sweet one and then one of them comes in
and she's at George Foreman you know
that gorilla one of them comes in that
gorilla boy and the gorillas be laying
down the law and that gorilla sometimes
will show you who's boss and that's
where it can be a little bit weird dude
that's where it can be a little bit
weird where the gorilla shows up and you
know that George Foreman shows up and
she just starts putting it on your
honour her lady in front of you after
you already got in there you know or
when you're about to be next you know
what I'm saying she's swinging away dude
she's you know batting practice and you
still over there in the batter's box you
know when you start getting nervous and
you know and she's bringing in fake
instruments to the game she got some
fake pecker tied to her you know to her
rib cage or something and that's how you
know they're getting into it and that's
okay I must his anything wrong with any
of this you know I mean hell I got a
lesbians haircut you know taking this
haircut I've styled it after different
lesbian cuts that I've seen you know
always my father told me I had the heart
of a lesbian when I was a child and I've
always tried to live up to his you know
things that I guess we all try to live
up to things that our father wants out
of us and the things that our father
tells us about us you know that always
reflects in us most of our lives but
yeah that can be intimidating man you
know that's how dude I'd love to know
more if you navigate those waters dude
if you out there hook fennan and black
Jim and out there baby I'd love to know
with that mighty Trista sippy if you get
into that tryst baby if you get into
that tryst man with those ladies now if
you bring your wife in G dude this is a
damn movie you're living in so you got
to Ohio eights you're out there gunning
with one man penis you got a you got a
man penis running on natural battery
power natural blood flow so I pop a five
mil Esaias for you get out there you
know what I'm saying put your dancing
shoes on you did because you don't want
you know what I'm saying you want you
don't want to show up to the ballpark
wearing sandals you know what I'm saying
so I'd pop a 5 milli just to stay in
just to stay in the you know state just
to keep balls in the field of play that
way if you fade out once you could chill
in the back
you know have you you know a snack you
know a small snack or something couple
orange slices and then get back out
there and be hitting that you know
gunning down on them late on that crotch
because at that point those ladies gonna
be tag team and your wife you know
you're gonna be sitting in the distance
they're gonna be up there tag-teaming
you know one of them's gonna be in havin
her a headlock I wanted to be flying off
the top ropes you know and putting
everything know putting a grill into the
mat and all of that you know and doing
different things you know doing um you
know leg locks doggy style leg locks and
all of them know it's gonna be I don't
know and then also will it be weird if
your wife sees you not perform super
well like you don't want to be you know
you don't want them to be going out
there at it you know one of them's got a
bunch of you know some yarn tied around
her waist and with that you know one of
them plastic Johnson's you know hanging
off her rib cage and she's you know she
straight up are buckling that clam on
the you know with her lady with her
lesbian lover and you're sitting on the
sidelines you know and your wife's Talon
off your forehead and [ __ ] and you only
was at at three or four minutes that
could be scary bro wow man this is
interesting because I can't even imagine
being in that situation all the things
if it could happen or would happen man
dude that's brave man that's really
really brave
you know if you get in there I'd love to
know a little bit more about it if it
does occur and if you get in there man
and things do get weird and you do start
to feel a certain way just you know be
honest I would say just say look ladies
I'm gonna let you guys enjoy each
other's company I'm gonna sit over here
and relax
you know because part of my problem is I
would get in there and think I had to be
this type of man you know that can be
started that can then then suddenly I'm
fighting my own self you know now I'm
thinking my dicks thinking you don't
want your dick think and dude that's
what you don't want and that's what
happens a lot of times these days all of
our men's dick are thinking and that's
why we're not able to achieve sexually
as much as we used to you know because
there's not as much natural you know
everybody stay everything's thinking
nowadays it's not as much nature
you know we're not riding our limbic
system as much as we used to and so
we're riding our thoughts and our
thoughts thoughts and you dick don't run
on thoughts you know I'm seeing your
dick runs on that on that fortitude you
know and that one drop of frickin uh on
that one drop of of booty LSD that the
Lord just dripped into your spine when
he made you that's what you and that
that just that formulates your whole
universe and keeps you out there in them
streets you know and keeps you out there
being able to have sex and do sex
naturally because that setting that
setting that there's natural causes you
have inside of you but man if you get
out there dude Wow oh well if you need
help man hit up our first caller that
EMT man he might be able to get out
there and help you out as well or maybe
that was you that called us EMT I can't
even remember now man my brain gets a
little bit bad because the hell it's
Sunday evening you know but my Saints
once so that's truly beautiful but yeah
man I appreciate him have I ever been in
an instance like that I'll tell you this
dude I got in this three-way activity
once I mean I forgot about this I got in
this three-way activity out there in
Missouri and that's the swinger country
these are probably young swingers I
hadn't grown up yet and gotten married
and say we're just and one of these
girls real sexy you know real real sexy
you know like if you saw her at a bus
stop and it wasn't your stop you might
get off the bus just have a shot to talk
with her and then walk to your stop you
know as long as it wasn't raining you
might do that if you saw this girl but
and her friend looked kind of she was a
little bit Baltic Avenue if you know
what I'm saying man she wasn't I mean
this first baby was damn Marvin gardens
you know what I'm saying she was already
around that third corner you know she
was that kind of look but this first
baby you know this little baby cat was
uh she was a little more Baltic and and
that's fine man she was a sweet girl
both sweet girls and I went into it just
saying look I'm gonna do what I can but
that Baltic baby she had she kind of you
ever seen like those old like
weightlifting videos or from like the
1700s or whatever where the guy has the
dumbbells and it's the big round
dumbbells and it says like
1,000 on each side and he's like holding
it up and he's wearing like a unitard
you know she looked like that you know
she had that Bulgarian swagger in her
you know she had that you know that
Russian she was like she looked actually
about 90% Russian you know and then and
so she was like you know so I was trying
to really make love to the more you know
the one that I felt you know the one
that was more of a looker you know the
one that I wouldn't mind you know seeing
again and then her friend was more she
was that wrastler you know she kept
wrapping her leg she would do crazy [ __ ]
I remember like I remember I was doing a
little bit of doggy style activity that
rear entry position with the woman on
her knees and me the man back behind her
and then the lid the lady that little
you know that little wah she was kind of
like a damn like us you know like it's
like a um like a fast sloth she kind of
was on my back kind of rot almost
jockeying me you know she like she's on
my back jockey and me and I'm trying to
be you know I was almost that middle man
you know a little bit it's almost like
she was like this this [ __ ] fast
Russian backpack I was wearing you know
and she had her crotch on and she was
doing all kinds of she was almost doing
stunts and [ __ ] around us while we while
me and this other girl were making love
and then you know one of them is both I
was sitting on top of me and it was [ __ ]
was wild dude [ __ ] was wild man but it
was pretty enjoyable but there's also
just a lot going on so you don't know
it's hard to know when to you know where
you're supposed to be that's it you
almost need like somebody to do the
blocking and do some okay you be here
okay you know when the music stops
everybody get in a chair you know you
almost need you know you need a lot
going on you know you almost need a
referee or somebody like a wedding
planner if you want a real successful
threesome one thing but outside of that
you know a different time in Indiana I
was with to Indiana sixes and those are
Mississippi nines and and they
and that that's actually I think
Mississippi da half is in beautiful
women actually that's not true
and the and they were cousins man and we
did some really short quick sexuality
full-time sex but at part-time you know
at part-time full-time it was full-time
sex but more at part-time you know
part-time interest because I wasn't
super fired up but those were you know
those were different days
alright man but thank you for calling
you good luck out there I'd looked in a
little bit more about it if you if you
get into it man I want to hear a little
bit more about this next all right here
here we go Oh Missouri a swinger country
that's where that threesome all just
talking about in with that Bulgarian you
know with that backpack Bulgarian number
order she had like in Japanese name -
what was it um and um maybe sensei or
something sensei her name could have
been citizen since a here we go homework
so question for you how to handle
something summer I'm kind of short I
don't really go out of confidence myself
when I met the bars with other people
cuz you know I don't really know how to
talk to a girl or do anything like that
so yeah man I don't know what uh I don't
know how to handle it man I just get in
my head I don't know how to overcome
that seems like you could have some good
advice on this one let me know thanks
man
well Brock I appreciate you calling man
I appreciate this I appreciate you
sharing will it being willing to share
you know what your what your thoughts
are on what you see as a problem for
yourself and what you feel as a problem
for yourself or a difficulty you know
let's don't label it a problem you know
it's a difficulty that you're having you
know you're lacking some confidence
there you you feel like it's associated
with your height and you have trouble
then you know you know at the bars you
know we're probably
or I'm thinking in the I'm assuming more
I'm going to assume more in the vein of
meeting women you know and you know and
I know you're talking about that so you
know I'm kind of like a average height
of dude I'm kind of stumpy you know but
I'm kind of an average height of dude I
think so I'm gonna ask some of our
listeners if you guys will hit the
hotline for Brock nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three do it now
do after you listen if you are you know
a man of a shorter height or a woman of
a or not shorter but of a height that
you know would have been popular in like
the late 1800s or whatever or if you are
a woman who has you know your perception
of a man who is you know of a smaller
stature you know what give us some
thoughts on that you know give some
insight to Brock you know he sounds like
kind of a younger dude so give him you
know some thoughts let's let's let's
let's open up our brains to him because
this is something I can't associate on I
cannot you know and I'll share some
thoughts but I'm gonna let you know
Brock that I'm gonna do a follow up I'm
gonna take a couple of the listeners
calls and I'm gonna put them together on
a follow-up for you this week and we'll
post that up and that'll be just for you
so you can listen everybody can check it
out but that'll be just for you to to to
get other people's insights what my
insights are when it comes to lack of
confidence is you know sometimes you can
gain confidence from other people you
know and I don't know if you have a
group of other men you know that make
you feel kind of confident with who you
are no matter what I made some I did
some weird [ __ ] in my life over the
years dude man I'm gonna tell you this I
never told anybody this bro when I was
in high school you know cuz my eyes kind
of go down I got that polish mindset you
know and Polish people look a little bit
dead from like the middle of their from
the bottom of their forehead to like the
top of their nose they are eyes dyed
something happen to us it's almost like
somebody just you know like like they
cut off the power you know when they
were making our our eyes and stuff we
just look a little dead nah so you have
to lighten you have to you know spark up
sometimes to look interested and when I
was young I felt just super inferior
my eyes for some reason and so dude I
wore I didn't wear it but I put eyedrops
in my eyes 40 times a day man there
wasn't a day brach that I didn't have
eyedropper on me all day dude I don't
even know why like what did I just and
my weird mind I had you know no one had
ever said anything about my eyes you
know one kid he called me Chinese one
time you know and that's fine whatever
you know the Chinese they're plentiful
and they're you know they have great
spices and everything I've learned now
but you know but one kid had just made
fun of me for that or said that you know
but I just had this in my head that I
was it my eyes were weird and everything
and then next thing you know I'm doing
eye drops and then I was living with a
family when I was in high school and one
of the girls had a eyelash curler dude
and we had picture day at school and I
just felt you know I'd never seen an
eyelash curler and then I saw her using
it and then I was like man I want to
have better eyes you know I want to have
better eyes so I used a woman's eyelash
curler
you know and it's not a hot iron where
you're like [ __ ] you know getting a
damn heated one close to your face it's
just a you know one you just a little
when you use its little metal one but I
curled my damn eyelashes dude you know
and went to school and and I'm oh I
remember and I had this jacket on right
and then at recess or whatever I took
the jacket off it's Louisiana you know
wear a jacket for nine minutes in the
morning I had it off and somebody put
their hand in in my jacket pocket was
like sitting and I moved chair so it was
on the back of my chair somebody took my
chair at lunch or whatever put the hands
in pulled this eyelash curler out dude
and somebody's like do what the [ __ ] is
this right and and literally bruh I'm
sitting there with these girl on picture
day dude all because I felt inferior
about the way that I looked man but I'll
tell you this bro that I notice here's
my perspective
geyser of smaller stature or not
horizontally gifted or whatever you know
little you know sweet little gentleman
they look better they can get muscle on
them you know so you you do curls for
two weeks you gonna you gonna be jet you
know but but longer people they got to
do longer work to get the muscle I think
that's a gift
I think smaller guys do better at stuff
like wrasslin you know looking for
things that are on the ground do it if
you're tall that's a [ __ ] come on
dude you could put your back out but a
small friend to help you find anything
that could be on the ground you know
that's easy for them that's natural you
know so I think there's a lot of
advantages to being of a smaller stature
but I think helping to find a group of
people that support you how you feel no
matter what will probably increase some
of that confidence but I'll say this
about bars as well I never felt
confident in a bar you know especially
not at a nightclub you know but I never
felt super confident at a bar it's a
weird environment where there's a lot of
alcohol you know you know rowdy people
are being rowdy you know sometimes it's
not always my vibe you know especially a
nightclub and actually bars I wasn't as
bad but a nightclub you know I felt
inferior a lot of times man I felt in
fear there's always something wrong with
me so yeah we got to increase your
confidence Brock and I don't know
exactly how to do it but I know you're
not the only person who thinks about
those things about themselves we all
have something wrong with ourselves you
know so I mean if you're a smaller
stature you get to be that [ __ ]
Mighty Mouse you could be [ __ ] for
Halloween I could never be dude you know
I'm saying you could be a gerbil you
know you could be a um you know you
could be Danny DeVito you know you could
be what else could you be Oh Sonic the
Hedgehog you know you got access to kind
of smaller scale costumes you know and
that's that's pretty you know that's a
rarity you know and I know some of these
ideas maybe aren't helpful but I'm
thinking some of our other people can
give you helpful ideas so if you guys
have hit the hotline for Brock if you're
smaller sort of stature how we can
increase some of his confidence
I'll share those in a separate video
we'll put that up on Wednesday or
Thursday I'm gonna say Thursday so to
give me a little more time to get it
done alright let's hear a little bit
more next caller hey Theo state from
Texas just got you know listen to the
podcast and stop talking about
relationships and all that I just got
out of a thing with this girl she was
kind of like a long-distance thing and
you know she kind of said she wanted to
break not break things off but take a
break for a while well she figure stuff
out because we're both busy people we
have children we have you know one child
each you know what I mean okay so you're
in a long-distance relationship you got
one child each and you're already in a
long-distance relationship and now you
want to take a break
okay homework yeah both got one child
each okay like that you know stuff like
that I mean you we're talking about
children here but yeah that's just
that's children man that's not stuff
like that stuff like that is some books
or something you know or some you know a
box of hats but I feel you though onward
all that stuff's kind of like not making
sense right now so I guess taking a
little break but I was just wondering if
you had any advice for people who are
like you know kind of depressed about
that situation you know it can't be with
somebody that you want even though you
want to or you know sometimes you just
don't want to get out of bed and go to
work just because you're thinking about
all that and yeah man I appreciate this
call yeah I can relate to this man I had
a girlfriend of his long distance and I
you know I loved her as much as I knew
about love at the time you know I loved
her she was worth loved you know she was
worth me loving she was worth me caring
about she was a good person and I wasn't
a good dude you know I was running
around I was you know cheating you know
you know I made some poor choices you
know snacking on some you know distant
crotch out in the distance and doing
that kind of deal but she was and she
made some poor choices we both you know
we both
tried our best because it was long
distance that was the that's the
correlation with yours or the parallel
is that his long distance you know but
when she finally shut me off and it was
really the best thing to do because I
was just volatile man I wouldn't show
her as much affection and stuff but then
once she shut me off I was all I was
like all over you know I was you know
then everything was so severe and we
were so in love you know I was just like
deep in that [ __ ] like that you know I
was in there like that and part of that
ended up just being a problem in
hindsight that I had him you know I had
this issue of my own there's some that
was my own issue you know it wasn't I
mean there was some stuff about her you
know I missed her and stuff like that
but but I I didn't have any I think I
look to her for more than a relationship
I was looking to her to fulfill some
role that was impossible for her to
fulfill like I was looking for her to be
my happiness that's what I was looking
for man I know that may sound crazy but
I was looking for her to be my happiness
and that's and that's not realistic you
know you can't put that pressure on
somebody because they'll never live up
to it you know they're never gonna be
able to be that you know they can help
you know they'll be part time happiness
for you but they're never gonna be able
to fully fulfill that and so I didn't
realize I put that pressure on her but
once we split up dude I was just like my
whole life is over you know even though
my life had been kind of you know we
were long-distance we were you know my
life had been kind of okay you know so I
found for me I put like this invisible
pressure and in the end it was more
about you know me figuring out well why
do I feel you know why do I feel alone
you know why do I feel this alone
because it wasn't really her filling me
up that much making me feel on alone
you know and whenever she left it
sparked this thing because that's how I
got Brad got depressed I'm chilling at
the house you know I mean serials I mean
in a box of cereal a day dude you know
what I'm saying like a damn like a
mentally challenged person or like a you
know like a second wife that's not you
know pulling their weight you know I'm
just at home eating a box of cereal a
day you know and I was started doing
menthol cigarettes in the backyard and I
was just so depressed and I was putting
it all on her but the truth was for me
that I was alone that I was feeling
empty no matter and whatever what
happened with her just sparked it was a
spark that set off that empty dynamite
inside of me that made me you know just
made me realize how empty I was you know
so I think maybe just I know it's a lot
it something like you have a child there
so I'd focus on that if you can you know
um honor some of those feelings when
you're missing her but don't let that
feeling if you can help it try and what
is that feeling oh man I miss her so
much you know I'm gonna go you know I'm
gonna be depressed
you know not want to get out of bed I'm
gonna do those types of things because
then there's more to it you know there's
more to it what else is there something
else are you missing you know are you
lacking a relationship with your mother
you know are you missing you know other
outlets that make you feel like you you
know find some [ __ ] to do I think you
know pick up a new hobby you know just
create more of you so that there's not
so much space in there for someone else
too that if they leave that there's so
much haunting there's so much space for
that haunting feeling because she's
maybe seem like maybe she's she's gone
and now those haunting feelings are just
bouncing off the walls inside you and
there's so much emptiness inside of you
because you're not filled up with some
of yourself or more of yourself and
those are just some thoughts man because
that's what that's what my problem was
in the end there wasn't enough of me
inside of me you know to hold me up you
know no matter who
came along you know and filled in that
other space I needed to give them less
space inside of me you know so that if
they came or went I was still had enough
fortitude to hold myself up no matter
who that was that came along so and I
don't know what some of those things are
it could be you know finding a local
group you know there's a group online
called mankind I know that helps men get
there you know just the men you know
fill ourselves up you know with with
whatever we need to to be better men in
a relationship or out of a relationship
and those are the thoughts man you know
but I do feel some of your pain man and
just know you're not alone in that game
bro I'm saying I bet on those [ __ ]
pain streets dude laying in my step
parents house lugging eating snacks dude
get armor and one time laying on the
ground and just pouring a full [ __ ]
can of planter's nuts into my mouth dude
and just wishing the devil would take me
or that the Lord would send me on that's
what I remember dude and that's [ __ ]
ain't some woman didn't really do that
to me
in hindsight something was empty inside
of me and I was trying to fill up with
these canned nuts you know and asking
for the devil so but I appreciate your
call man that's it that's a good bit of
calls we have some other cool ones man
we got a call about a sperm center that
I wanted to get to but I'm not gonna get
to it today because you know with I just
feel like I don't like taking up too
much time but actually you know what man
I'll put some I got to do some extra
stuff for the patreon I want to thank my
patreon supporters and and I want to
thank all of my listeners man and I want
to thank the callers nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three hit the
hotline you know and that's it you know
it's you know we're all battling
something you know and that's something
to remember whether you feel interest
you feeling short in stature you know
whether you feeling you know you know if
you get into a threesome how will I hold
up you know will I still be able to you
know take my man you know be a man talk
to your wife for you go in you guys are
on the same team in that thing you know
it's like the old school it's like you
know it's like
Shawn Michaels and Marty Jannetty the
rockers versus versus Hawk and animal
you know it's like an old wrestling you
know that's like wrestling you know a
foursome that's like wrestling going
there with a teammate you know have a
referee hire a referee even you know to
make sure that everything runs smoothly
if you need to in that instance but we
all have questions you know we all have
questions every day that we're asking
ourselves and that we're asking each
other you know and sometimes get
somebody else's perception and and and
try not to make things too heavy if you
can you know you might be a little
shorter this time and maybe you five you
know five this time you know but maybe
next time you six four you know and you
a brother and you dunk it on people you
know in the mean streets of Chicago you
know so you don't know what you're gonna
get next time you know and this is all
part time you know but just don't be
alone out there ask somebody for help if
you need help if you need assistance if
you need just somebody else to shoulder
your burden man because once you tell
somebody else your problem instead of
sitting on two shoulders now it's riding
on for maybe a little bit lighter isn't
it but I appreciate you guys hitting me
up man imma [ __ ] try to keep my [ __ ]
together dude jeepers you know I just
sometimes just get selfish man that's
what I find I just want to you know I
don't want to do things sometimes for
other people and I want to just think
about myself as something that I've been
you know I just got to we got to get
free of ourselves man we got to we got
to I appreciate you guys be well man
take care of yourselves
let's hit this original on the way out
this is Spencer Jacob growl band
celebrate
[Music]
celebrate it man
celebrate it don't take things too
seriously you know if somebody's dying
finish your fries you know what I'm
saying
[Music]
life serious enough dude
go home love your family love yourself
[Music]
that'll help man thank you guys for
being here for me today this week this
past weekend you guys take care
[Music]